>>I generally wake up,
5:30 every morning.
Some days mo-- try to work
out and get all the running.
I go to the gym and then try to
get to school around 7:00, 7:15.
I wish I could get here
earlier, but you can't.
Working after school is impossible.
So that has to happen in the
morning if it's gonna to happen.
Then from there, I generally sit
down, put my computer, turn it on.
I meet with the RISE students
in the morning first thing.
And then from day to day it
changes, whether you know--
there's meetings each day,
whether it's individual check-ins
with my grade level chairs, meetings
with grade level chairs as a group.
You know, meetings with Mark,
the school director and the rest
of the admin team on Mondays.
And then parent office hours and
trying to schedule when those happen.
And generally, you know, it probably
goes until 6:00 plus each night.
Come home and eat and then start--
actually it's hard for me personally
and some people may be
better at this than myself,
but to get the bigger projects
done at school or even replying
to emails that take some thought.
A lot of that has to
happen at home at night.
So generally I like
to kind of unwind.
I'm not much of a sleeper.
So I like to unwind and
maybe whether, you know,
there's a basketball game on or
whatever it may be, you know,
I like to make dinner
and so forth and do that.
And then I'll kind of settle down
at the desk around 10:00, 10:30.
And I generally- generally work
until about 12:30, 1:00 each night
and do it all again the next day.
I used to be a lot stronger at Friday
happy hours, but now come Friday,
my body, it's shutdown time.
And so I maybe only go
out for a drink or two.
But yeah, I don't stay out very
late on Fridays very longer.
To build relationships with students
you really, really have to go
out of your way to try to put
yourself in their- in their position
and to open up to them and
show that you're vulnerable
and you've overcome some obstacles
and you've faced challenges.
While you know, I would
never even try to pretend
that what I've overcome in my life is
anywhere near what our students have
to overcome to get to college.
But you know, we all overcome
some challenges and rec--
being open to them about that.
But at the same time remaining
or keeping that, you know,
authoritative presence that-
that they still respect you.
They can open up to you and say a
lot of things but yet they want to,
at the same time kind of
impress you because they are--
they look up to you for who you
are and for being vulnerable.
I think it is definitely scalable.
I think the one thing
that we have going
that the large ISDs
don't have, is the size.
You know, having an
extremely large high school
and extremely large middle
school, it's just too hard
to know what's going on and if I
can quality control how students are
doing, to get to know the student,
because that's a huge part,
that relationship building.
And even as an administrator, the
fact that I can name you know,
first and last name of every
student in this school,
I think plays a huge part.
So when I walk around, it's just
not hey buddy, hey you guys.
It's you know, hello Jose.
Hey Priscilla, how is
your day going so far?
And I think that's-
that's a big part of it.
And I don't know if larger schools,
you know, if they have the ability
to break down into
smaller communities.
I think that's one thing that
would be advantageous for them.
But I think it's-- the
scalability is there.
In my first year in the role of
principal going from, you know,
full time teacher into
principal, I just realized
in how many directions you
get pulled throughout the day.
Whether it's, you know, a parent
all of a sudden shows up and wants
to meet or a student discipline
issue gets brought to you.
And on top of that
having to, you know,
create agendas for upcoming meetings.
Projects that need to
take place and whether
to make a final exam schedule, submit
some paperwork to the home office
and trying to do it all at the same
time and being accessible to everyone
at all times on top of getting in
the classrooms where I need to be.
Observing teachers, getting
a feel for the students,
just being a presence around campus,
I wasn't doing a very good job.
So looking at that, what I did for--
halfway through last year
and then set myself up again
to do it this year, is just really--
took a couple weeks where I just
wrote down everything that I'm doing
in a day, you know, every
half an hour, what am I doing?
What am I doing?
I kind of collected all of
that and figured out okay,
I need to block out some time.
And also let staff know
that the open door poss-
the open door policy still exists.
But you know, if people are just
coming in and out at any time,
then I'm not going to be very
effective in my job in terms
of getting in the classrooms.
We are all committed to one
thing and that is recognizing
that our students need more than
what's being offered currently
by their zone public school,
because they're not gonna
have the opportunity to go
to a four year college with the
education they're receiving.
So that- that core mission, that
that's what we're all here for,
is ensuring that our students
are prepared to graduate
from a four year college,
that common bond, you know,
is what makes us successful.
And that's true of any
successful organization, you know.
We use like the Southwest
Airlines example.
Everyone knows that they're a low
cost, you know, low fare airline.
And that's what they are.
That's what they're really good at.
And I think that's kind of
the way we look at ourselves.
As we are-- we're not
gonna overtake any ISD.
We're not trying to become the
biggest school district in Houston.
But we do want to try to push
education in the city of Houston
to show that it is possible
and hopefully continue
to build relationships with the
ISD that they can then, you know,
learn from what's been
successful for us and we can learn
from what's worked for
them and hopefully,
create a city specifically
in Houston
where we're sending more
students off to college.
>>For more information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org